Shure: 没了就
Shure: It's done then
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Jake:倒吧
Jake: Pour it
Shure: 我刚开哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: I just started hahaha
Jake:服了哎哈哈哈哈哈哈哈没关系
Jake: I'm impressed, haha, it's alright
Lucia:接力赛了成
Lucia: It's a relay now
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah
Shure: 我这开的是不是有点多余了
Shure: Did I start too early?
Jake:你不多余
Jake: No, you're fine
Jake:你开的挺好
Jake: You did great
Alice:那老师我可以下班了
Alice: So can I clock out now, boss?
Jake:对你可以下班
Jake: Yes, you can clock out
Alice:明天要早点起来上钟呃对
Alice: Gotta get up early tomorrow for work, right?
Jake:呃对
Jake: Uh, yeah
Shure: 呃是的
Shure: Uh, yes
Lucia:我现在深深怀疑
Lucia: I'm seriously doubting
Lucia:我明天能不能把自己房子装修完
Lucia: If I can finish renovating my house tomorrow
Jake:你现在还差多少
Jake: How much more do you have left?
Lucia:嗯我得把这个玩意给他剪下来
Lucia: Well, I need to cut this thing off
Jake:我们可以有
Jake: We can
Jake:我们可以找人帮你来做
Jake: We can find someone to help you with it
Alice:我可能需要一个小时哦
Alice: I might need an hour though
Lucia:啊我
Lucia: Ah, I...
Jake:明天
Jake: Tomorrow
Lucia:对
Lucia: Yeah
Jake:明天9点
Jake: Tomorrow at 9
Alice:9点 晚吗
Alice: 9 o'clock, is that too late?
Jake:9点可以啊
Jake: 9 o'clock is fine
Jake:9点把眼镜塞
Jake: At 9, we start
Jake:其实对九九点也9点
Jake: Yeah, 9 o'clock, we'll start at 9
Jake:你们基本上都在自己房间里面活动了
Jake: You guys will mostly be in your rooms
Jake:所以说9点直接把眼镜塞给你们
Jake: So at 9, we'll hand it over to you guys
Jake:你们自己搞去吧
Jake: You handle it yourselves
Lucia: 还需要
Lucia: Still need
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Alice:他把快递拿过来
Alice: He'll bring the package over
Jake:还有快递
Jake: There's still a package?
Jake:那快递他妈可慢了
Jake: That delivery is so slow
Jake:呵呵呵
Jake: Haha
Alice:那他要自己去拿吗
Alice: Does he have to pick it up himself?
Jake:自己自己拿也更慢的
Jake: It's even slower to get it yourself.
Lucia:哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:呵呵呵呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehehe
Lucia:我们今天去的路上还顺便去了一趟彩店
Lucia: On our way today, we stopped by a lottery shop.
Jake:进他亏了20
Jake: He ended up losing 20.
Lucia:对然后每每人刮了一张
Lucia: Yes, and each of us scratched one ticket.
Alice:亏了20 刮了一张
Alice: Lost 20, scratched one ticket each.
Jake:捐了20万福利彩票福利了20块钱
Jake: Donated 200,000 to the lottery, benefiting 20 bucks.
Shure: 只有他挣了10块
Shure: Only he made 10 bucks.
Lucia:实现盈利的只有他
Lucia: He was the only one who made a profit.
Shure: 对
Shure: Right.
Lucia:每个人都买了
Lucia: Everyone bought one.
Lucia:但最后实现盈利的只有他
Lucia: But in the end, he was the only one who made a profit.
Jake:最后你还是行了
Jake: In the end, you still managed it.
Shure: 我本来是
Shure: I was originally...
Shure: 然后最最开始最后又给他alllin回去
Shure: At first, then in the end, I went all-in back to him.
Jake:结果
Jake: So in the end...
Jake:还亏了20是吧
Jake: Still lost 20, right?
Shure: 是的就相当于亏了20
Shure: Yes, it’s equivalent to losing 20.
Lucia:算一下这个赔率
Lucia: Let's calculate this odds.
Shure: 好那明天我们在上面进行知识问答
Shure: Alright, tomorrow we'll have a quiz up there.
Shure: 还是在下面一位啊
Shure: Or should we do it downstairs?
Jake:在上面上面
Jake: Upstairs, upstairs.
Jake:椅子下面吃东西
Jake: Eating under the chair.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Mm-hmm.
Jake:包括外面
Jake: Including outside.
Jake:是你记得调酒
Jake: Do you remember to mix the drinks?
Alice:那明天那个甜品啊
Alice: So, for tomorrow's dessert...
Shure: 好
Shure: Got it.
Alice::调酒那些准备的
Alice: The drinks will be prepared.
Jake:早上开始干
Jake: Start in the morning.
Alice:那他们什么时候装修房子
Alice: When will they start renovating the house?
Jake:呃装修房子
Jake: Uh, renovating the house...
Lucia:我们明天早上
Lucia: We will start tomorrow morning.
Jake:装修房先把自己房子给装修好
Jake: Renovate the house, get our own house done first.
Jake:然后没啥事了下去做做
Jake: Then if there's nothing else, go down and help.
Jake:就是帮帮忙去
Jake: Just lend a hand.
Jake:对因为我们有一些同学同志
Jake: Yes, because we have some classmates, comrades.
Jake:他他没有房子要装修
Jake: They don't have houses to renovate.
Jake:哈哈哈对
Jake: Hahaha, right.
Shure: 我的我的房子
Shure: My, my house.
Jake:太完美了
Jake: It's perfect.
Jake:不需要装修
Jake: No need for renovation.
Shure: 比比较朴素
Shure: It's quite simple.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 我不喜欢花里胡哨
Shure: I don't like flashy stuff.
Alice:花里胡哨
Alice: Flashy stuff.
Jake:然后我们还有一些剧组人员
Jake: And we also have some crew members.
Shure: 我不喜欢花里胡哨
Shure: I don't like flashy stuff.
Jake:或者他的房子不在这个地方
Jake: Or his house isn't in this place.
Jake:这也不需要装修
Jake: This also doesn't need renovation.
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:就那些剧组可以帮各位装修
Jake: The crew can help you renovate if needed.
Jake:如果有有需要的话
Jake: If there's any need.
Shure: 所以剧组成员帮我写论文吧
Shure: So the crew can help me write my thesis then.
Alice:明天剧组都来了
Alice: The crew's coming tomorrow.
Jake:都来都会来
Jake: They'll all come.
Jake:放心都会来
Jake: Don't worry, they'll all come.
Jake:拖家带口的来
Jake: Bringing their families.
Shure: 呃拖家带口啊
Shure: Uh, bringing their families?
Jake:谢明茹不拖家带口吗
Jake: Isn't Xie Mingru bringing his family?
Shure: 谢民主拖啥家啊
Shure: What family does Xie Minzhu have?
Jake:我问问他谢斌竹呢
Jake: I'll ask him, what about Xie Binzhu?
Shure: 他女朋友也不在北京啊
Shure: His girlfriend isn't in Beijing either.
Jake:那是你妈
Jake: That's your mom.
Shure: 怎么北京找了个分部
Shure: How did Beijing get a branch?
Jake:你问问
Jake: You ask.
Lucia:啊对
Lucia: Ah, right.
Lucia:我今天也得洗个澡估计
Lucia: I think I need a shower today.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 那他们今天晚上回去吧
Shure: Are they going back tonight?
Shure: 刘帅回去是吧
Shure: Choiszt is going back, right?
Jake:他应该应该
Jake: He should, he should.
Jake:都回去都回去
Jake: Everyone's going back.
Shure: 都回去是吧嗯
Shure: Everyone's going back, right?
Jake:没关系
Jake: No problem.
Lucia:我好想把这玩意直接贴墙啊
Lucia: I really want to stick this thing directly to the wall.
Jake:直接贴墙上
Jake: Stick it directly to the wall.
Lucia:因为咱因为我又害怕到时候撕不下来
Lucia: Because, because I'm afraid it won't come off later.
Lucia:因为咱这剪刀太难用了
Lucia: Because these scissors are just too hard to use.
Lucia:我根本给他剪不齐
Lucia: I can't cut it evenly at all.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Lucia:就是人家本来是这样的
Lucia: Like, it was originally like this.
Lucia:看哦就这意思
Lucia: Look, this is what I mean.
Lucia:不知道这粘了会不会留印但是就
Lucia: I don't know if it will leave a mark when glued, but...
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:因为我没想到他是在一张纸上的
Lucia: Because I didn't realize it was on one sheet of paper.
Lucia:我以为他一个就是这样的哦
Lucia: I thought each one was like this, oh.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia:我就直接把他往上
Lucia: So I just went ahead and...
Lucia:就拿个美人纸一bia就完事了
Lucia: Just grabbed some paper and slapped it on.
Jake:是
Jake: Yes.
Lucia:吃了没有生活经验的亏
Lucia: I suffered from lack of life experience.
Shure: 吃的没有生活经验
Shure: Suffered from lack of life experience.
Lucia:然后想想这个这样其实也行
Lucia: But thinking about it, this way actually works too.
Lucia:但是就是他这个这个边就不好看
Lucia: But the edge just doesn't look good.
Jake:剪不了吧
Jake: Can't cut it, right?
Jake:我来剪
Jake: I'll cut it.
Lucia:剪剪到是能剪
Lucia: I can cut it though.
Jake:我来剪一刀
Lucia:但是就是很难很难把它剪齐
Lucia: But it's really hard to cut it evenly.
Lucia:因为这个剪刀太难用了
Lucia: Because these scissors are so hard to use.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
Lucia:如果有另外那个剪刀的话还好点
Lucia: It would be better if we had the other scissors.
Lucia:哎
Lucia: Sigh.
Lucia:先把这个
Lucia: Let’s start with this.
Lucia:我
Lucia: I...
Jake:确实挺难用
Jake: They really are hard to use.
Lucia:是吧
Lucia: Right?
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake:但是可能还是可以剪
Jake: But maybe we can still cut it.
Jake:勉强
Jake: Barely.
Lucia:官方认证的难捡
Lucia: Officially certified as hard to cut.
Jake:对勉强可以剪嘛
Jake: Yeah, barely manageable.
Lucia:嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Lucia:我给墙上贴满美文纸
Lucia: I'll cover the wall with this decorative paper.
Lucia:然后把这个贴在美文纸上
Lucia: Then stick this on the decorative paper.
Jake:可以可以可以
Jake: Sounds good, sounds good.
Lucia:哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia:弱智程度堪比弱智吧了
Lucia: The level of stupidity is almost as bad as an idiot.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh no.
Shure: 那我的眼镜是不是又可以关了
Shure: Can I turn off my glasses again?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Lucia:同想问是可以关了吗
Lucia: I was also wondering if we can turn it off.
Lucia:我就去洗澡了哈
Lucia: I'm gonna take a shower.
Jake:可以啊可以啊关了吧
Jake: Yes, yes, go ahead and turn it off.
Shure: 随便漫无目的走一会吧
Shure: Let's just wander around aimlessly for a while.
Lucia:耶
Lucia: Yay.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Katrina: 干啥
Katrina: What's up?
Shure: 撞到我了
Shure: You bumped into me.
Shure: 快说对不起
Shure: Say sorry.
Katrina: 对不起辛巴塞
Katrina: Sorry, Simba-sai.
Jake:对补漆啊
Jake: Sorry, we need to repaint.
Katrina: 还是没有找到那个剪刀
Katrina: Still haven't found those scissors.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake:下了两刀
Jake: I made two cuts.
Katrina: 看来是做不成了
Katrina: Looks like it's not gonna work.
Shure: 我们结束了
Shure: We're done.
Shure: 我们的问卷
Shure: Our questionnaire.
Shure: 那弱智问题要有一些吗
Shure: Should there be some stupid questions?
Jake:可以有一些给我发一点
Jake: Yeah, send me some.
Lucia:为什么陨石总能落在陨石坑里
Lucia: Why do meteorites always land in craters?
Jake:对你你把这发
Jake: Yeah, send that to me.
Jake:给我我再给他加一点啊
Jake: I'll add a few more to it.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:你微信发我一份啊
Jake: Send me a copy on WeChat.
Shure: 这个问卷什么
Shure: What's with this questionnaire?
Jake:对我再加几个弱智问题就行
Jake: Yeah, I'll just add a few more stupid questions.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Katrina: 哎哦
Katrina: Oh no.
Jake:你大概拼一下吧
Jake: You roughly piece it together.
Jake:这DPQ题
Jake: This DPQ question.
Shure: 完了
Shure: Done.
Shure: 我给你找纸
Shure: I'll get you some paper.
Jake:好妙啊妙啊
Jake: Wonderful, wonderful.
Katrina: 给你张纸
Katrina: Here's a piece of paper.
Jake:什么纸
Jake: What paper?
Shure: 手纸
Shure: Toilet paper
Katrina: 呵呵
Katrina: Haha
Jake:草稿纸
Jake: Scrap paper
Jake:要干啥
Jake: What are you doing?
Katrina: paper
Katrina: Paper
Jake:paper paper
Jake: Paper, paper
Katrina: 呵呵呵paper paper
Katrina: Haha, paper, paper
Jake:来一封来一张paper
Jake: Give me a piece of paper
Shure: 我的配布只配用来擦这个你知道吗
Shure: My fabric is only good for wiping this, you know?
Katrina: paper
Katrina: Paper
Katrina: 对你的毕业论文喏
Katrina: For your thesis, you know
Jake:你的毕业论
Jake: Your thesis
Shure: 别你的我的的
Shure: Stop saying yours and mine
Shure: 我们的我的还没写出来呢啊
Shure: Ours, mine isn't even written yet
Katrina: 我的还没写出来呢还
Katrina: Mine isn't written yet either
Katrina: 都不配叫paper
Katrina: It's not even worthy to be called paper
Shure: 还是木浆呢是吧
Shure: It's still wood pulp, right?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:美
Jake: Beautiful
Shure: 我不
Shure: I don't
Jake:他会跳的他明天会跳的他明天会跳的
Jake: He will dance, he will dance tomorrow, he will dance tomorrow
Shure: 会
Shure: He will
Lucia: 他应该跳一个
Lucia: He should dance
Shure: 我不会我不会的
Shure: I won't, I won't
Jake:气氛到了他明天会跳的
Jake: When the mood is right, he'll dance tomorrow
Katrina: 谁啊他跳呗
Katrina: Who, him? Let him dance
Jake:啊他啊他
Jake: Yeah, him
Jake:雨轩也跳
Jake: Yuxuan will dance too
Jake:你们也跳
Jake: You guys dance too
Shure: 噔噔噔噔
Shure: Dun dun dun dun
Jake:你们你们仨跳吧
Jake: You three dance
Jake:站中间那
Jake: Stand in the middle
Lucia: 那现在没排的话我们三freestyle
Lucia: If there's no routine now, we'll freestyle
Shure: 我
Shure: I
Jake:可以啊
Jake: Sure
Shure: 们仨battle开始
Shure: The three of us battle, start
Katrina: 我天啊
Katrina: Oh my god
Jake:你三battle
Jake: You three battle
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha
Jake:我觉得可以哈哈
Jake: I think it's doable, haha.
Lucia: 明天本来想穿裙子的话还得穿裤子
Lucia: If I wanted to wear a skirt tomorrow, I'd have to wear pants instead.
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 没有在地下先转个瓶
Shure: Didn't spin a bottle underground first.
Shure: 歘哈哈哈
Shure: Shoo haha.
Katrina: 天
Katrina: Oh my God.
Shure: 知道这
Shure: You know this.
Katrina: 垃圾桶呢
Katrina: Where's the trash can?
Katrina: 每天都在找东西
Katrina: Always looking for stuff every day.
Shure: 来吃了吧
Shure: Come on, let's eat.
Jake:找啥了paper啊
Jake: What are you looking for, paper?
Katrina: 垃圾桶垃圾桶
Katrina: Trash can, trash can.
Jake:垃圾桶不在
Jake: The trash can isn't here.
Katrina: 垃圾桶配paper
Katrina: Trash can goes with paper.
Jake:很配paper trash can
Jake: Fits perfectly with paper, trash can.
Lucia: 绝配啊
Lucia: Perfect match.
Shure: （歌词）i found the love
Shure: (lyrics) I found the love.
Katrina: 放歌
Katrina: Play the song.
Shure: （歌词）  for me
Shure: (lyrics) For me.
Jake:for you
Jake: For you.
Katrina: 我看能不能做个一条呢
Katrina: Let's see if I can make one.
Shure: 发给杨老板
Shure: Send it to Jake.
Katrina: 其他的朋友们呢
Katrina: What about the other friends?
Katrina: 你知道第一天我几点起的吗
Katrina: Do you know what time I got up on the first day?
Katrina: 你不在那天8点
Katrina: You weren't there, 8 o'clock that day.
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
Katrina: 后来就再也没有起来过
Katrina: Then I never got up early again.
Jake:哪一天
Jake: Which day?
Katrina: 今睡迟了的
Katrina: The day I slept in.
Katrina: 第二天
Katrina: The second day.
Katrina: 我以为我们就是有严格按照时间表
Katrina: I thought we were strictly following the schedule.
Katrina: 10点半准时开始
Katrina: Start promptly at 10:30.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahahaha.
Katrina: 呵呵后来知道了以后
Katrina: Then I realized later,
Katrina: 我就理所当然的不定闹钟了
Katrina: I didn't set an alarm anymore,
Katrina: 等他来敲门呵
Katrina: Just waited for him to knock on the door, haha.
Katrina: 好又要下楼一趟
Katrina: Alright, gotta go downstairs again.
Katrina: 热熔胶
Katrina: Hot glue.
Lucia: 我先把我的那个串都拆开看看
Lucia: I'll first take apart my stuff and see.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Shure: 让我想一想
Shure: Let me think about it.
其他人:结束了你给我发了吗
Others: Did you send it to me when you finished?
Shure: 好的我先
Shure: Okay, I'll do it first.
Jake:哈哈哈结束了
Jake: Hahaha, it's over.
Shure: 我再借那什么借麦克风
Shure: Can I borrow that, borrow the microphone?
Jake:结束准备换卡换
Jake: It's over, get ready to change the card.
Jake:开始出开始papida了
Jake: Start, start papida.
Jake:上papada呢
Jake: It's on papida now.
Jake:打工
Jake: Working.
其他人：换卡换卡
Others: Change the card, change the card.
其他人：这个大的
Others: This big one.
Jake:对换卡
Jake: Yes, change the card.
Shure: 不行我这眼镜得摘
Shure: No, I need to take off these glasses.
Katrina: 哎呀呀呀呀哎呀
Katrina: Oh my, oh my, oh my.
Shure: 谢明主
Shure: Thanks, kind master.